من شربها حذرت وزاره الدفاع الكوريه
الجنوبيه بيان بيانغ من محاوله استخدام
اسلحه النوويه
عن الوزاره ان الجيش الكوريه الجنوبيه
سيعزز بشكل كبير قدرته على تنفيذ الردع
الموسع
واشاره الوزاره
عن تطوير الاسلحه النوويه والعوده الى
طريق نزع السلاح النووي
سوكا
بشكل خطير في المنطقه وهددت الابناء
والاستقرار فيها
احتجاجا لكوريا
العام الماضي
تهدد امن وسلامه اليابان المنطقه والمجتمع
الدولي ويجب ان لا يسمح بذلك
كوريا
نعم مرحبا بكم بالمشاهدين وكل عام وانتم
بخير بالفعل كوريا الشماليه اطلقت هذا
الصاروخ صبيحه اول ايام هذا العام الجديد
ويحتفل العالم با الالعاب الناريه ويبدا
رغبت ان تحتفل معها طوكي وصول بيه هذا
الصاروخ الذي اطلقته فجر اليوم بطبع كان
هناك استدعاء سريعه لوزير الدفاع
اليابانيه عاده من اجازته التي
لم تنقطع بهذا الشكل منذ سنوات طويله لان
كوريا الشماليه همم لاول مره تطلق صاروخ
في ليله العام الجديد وهذه سابقه تسجل لها
بالفعل همم ليس فقط في همم لا تفاجئ فقط
في التوقيت ولكن ايضا بالوثيره هذا
الصاروخ الذي بدات بهذا العام الجديد يكمل
همم العام الاخير او ينهي العام الاخير في
حوالي همم سبعين وثلاثين تجربه صاروخيه
اطلقت خلالها سبعين صاروخا واذا قد بدات
هذا العام صريحه هذا العام بهذا الصاروخ
فربما بالفعل نشهد وتيره كبيره ومتسارعه
من هذه الصواريخ لان الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي كيم جون في الكلمه التي القاها
يوم امس في الاجتماع اللجنه العليا لحزب
العمال الحكم في كوريا الشماليه امر
بتسريع البرامج الصاروخيه لكوريا الشماليه
وايضا تسريعه القوه النوويه للبلاد بشكل
غير مسبوق وهذه الاوامر يبدو ان قوته بدات
تترجمها بالفال هناك فقارير منذ شهور
تتحدث عن اقتراب كوريا الشماليه من اجراء
تجربه نوويه همم جديده وهمم لا يخفي
الكليون الشماليون بان الصواريخ التي يطلق
عليها الان قادره على حمل همم رؤوس نوويه
اليوم في اعلان الذي نشر في وكاله الانباء
المركزيه لكوريا الشماليه يتحدث عن منصه
اطلاق متعدده الصواريخ لصواريخ يمكنها حمل
الرؤوس نوويه
صواريخ اطلقت يوم امس وهذه وهذا البيان
كان يتحدث عن الصواريخ الثلاثه التي اطلقت
يوم امس بانها قادره على حمل رؤوس نوويه
وانها قادره على ضرب اي مكان في كوريا
الجنوبيه وبطبع ايضا تغطي اليابان
والقواعد الامريكيه فيها ولذلك نبدا هذا
العام بالفعل بتوتر جديد وربما الايام او
السريعه المقبله ستكشف المزيد من هذه
البرامج التي تعهد الزعيم الكوري الشمالي
بانها
ستضمن ان بلاده عن طريق الردع كما يقول
شكرا جزيلا لك